اا الملك عبد الله يعني حاور او حاول ان
يحاور الاخوان في عده مرات او او في يعني
في بدايات حكمه فقط كانت التركيز الاساسي
شوف هما طلبوا مقابله الملك لما تولى
السلطه والملك رحب فيهم واعطاهم موعد فذهب
اربعه من الاخوان على راسهم عبد المجيد
النبات المراقب الاسبق للاخوان
ولكن الاخوان رايحين يعني مش محضرين حالهم
فلما دخلوا وجدوا ان الملك موجود ومعه
اربعه من رجال دوله رئيس الوزراء عبد
الرؤوف الروابده وجدوا سميح البطيخي مدير
المخابرات وجدو نايف القاضي وزير الداخليه
وجدوا فائز التراعنه مدير رئيس الديوان
الملكي وهؤلاء الاربعه كل واحد حامل الملف
والاخوان جايين معهم ولا شيء
اول كان هاي اللي بيرجع انه البروتوكولات
ما بنعرفها بصيرش يسال الملكين
نحن فكرنا اللقاء معك عبد المجيد بنبات
فقال له الملك حبيت انكم تتعرفوا على بعض
يعني عالي الدبلوماسيه فجلس على راس
الطاوله وجلس هذول الاربعه مقابل الاربعه
فبدات اتفضلوا
فبداوا يتحدثوا يتحدثوا وكان حديثهم مش
حديث مباركه لملك تولي السلطه حديث شكوى
الحكومه الحكومه الحكومه وهذا الحقيقه غير
مناسب كان من الاول لو في وعي سياسي انه
نبارك لك واحنا جنود في هذا البلد لخدمه
بلدنا وتطور بس مع السلامه لكن ما اثقلوا
هذا ولهذا الملك طلب من الاربعه اللي همم
رجال الدوله
همم وزير الداخليه قال
يتحدثوا في الخطب كده وزير ال- اا رئيس
الديوان بيقول تاتينا تقارير مدير
المخابرات ويقول في خلايا رئيس الحكومه
بيقول هذول بيحكوا قدامك شكل وراك شكل
يعني كان صاعق فان الملك يعني قال يبدو
انتم مختلفين في ما بينكم فاجلسوا كمل
لقاء كتفاهموا مع بعض
فما يعني اول لقاء له همم ضرورته انه
بيعطي انطباع فالملك ساصبح عن بعد يعني
وصاروا يطلبوا لقاءات ما يقابلهم واظن
انهم قطعت تلك اللقاءات يعني